it is time for the press preview our
first look at the front pages
as they hit our inbox uh over the
remainder of the hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the economics correspondent at the
spectator kate andrews
and political editor at the new
statesman stephen bush but first let's
run you through the pages that we have
uh i think starting with the telegraph
yeah
plans for vaccine passports to be a
legal requirement at large events are to
be scrapped
that's the telegraph's lead story
and the eye says that ministers are
planning to ramp up vaccinations in a
race to june 21st of course the date
when all covered restrictions are due to
be lifted
similar story in the express in a
picture of carrion boris as they
describe them at the daily mail though
reporting on new figures revealing that
many people are now waiting
two years for hip operations as a result
of lockdown
meanwhile the guardian reports that 70
schools have been built using
combustible
insulation that was banned in high rise
of high-rise buildings after the
grenfell tower disaster
and the mirror goes with this headline
taste of freedom
uh million of millions of us not me
headed to the beach
after lockdown and well plenty of wet
weather
here's the ft it reports that u.s
authorities are taking a more active
role regulating the cryptocurrency
market
currently worth if you can believe this
one and a half trillion dollars
and the daily star has a story about
aliens the truth
is out there
not sure if that's on the list i'll have
a quick check kate anders and stephen
bush here to take you through
their choice of the papers good to see
you again guys um and
kate to you first take us to the front
page of the eye the 21st of june
a date looming large in many people's
minds including no doubt the prime
minister
and it's all about getting the vaccines
into people before them
yes so this has been a welcome change in
tone now um for
several weeks because back in february
march even parts of april
uh the government came dangerously close
to talking down the vaccines they were
suggesting they weren't 100
effective of course essentially no
vaccine is
we have very very highly effective
vaccines for coven 19 but they wanted
people to continue to obey the lockdown
rules for a few weeks longer
before the real opening up began but now
i think we're having a much more honest
conversation with the public which is
that of course vaccines
are the way out of this and as the prime
minister indicated a few weeks ago
they're hoping that the vaccination
process
can really beat the virus which is why
they're truncating that period of time
between when people um in slightly more
vulnerable groups people over the age of
50
are going to be getting their first and
second jab so
i think the major thing to be looking
out for is how quickly they can
ramp up that process and also make sure
they're still administering those first
jabs
uh to to the younger age groups who are
more likely
to spread the virus they're
significantly less likely to go into
hospital or die from this virus but they
are more likely
to spread it and what's happening to
infectious hospitalizations and deaths
along the way
now we would still need to wait a few
weeks to see what the opening on the
17th of may
uh really has done but so far
hospitalizations remain 97
below the peak deaths remain 99 below
the peak
so the most up-to-date information we
have is that the government is still
you know sort of kicking the can down
the road a little bit trying to put off
that
big 21st of june announcement for a few
more weeks we're now expecting around
the 14th of june
but if that hospitalization and those
deaf figures do stay
at some record lows since that third or
since that second wave
you would hope to see major reopening on
the 21st of june as those are the
metrics that matter most in this crisis
stephen what is the mood around sw1 and
whether or not
that 21st of uh june date will hold i
mean
on the front page of the eye underneath
the headline it alludes to that
uh article from secure starmer yesterday
you know claiming that it was
incompetence by boris johnson and others
and government might put
those plans for unlocking at risk i mean
that will weigh
uh on the prime minister's mind in terms
of the political decision-making
well yes precisely and that's one of the
reasons why if you speak to say the
average conservative mp about what they
think is going to happen
they will say look reopening has to
happen on the 21st of march we've had
quite enough of lockdown
and then they'll add and the reason why
the prime minister will ultimately
realize that
is he will understand that if we end up
locked down uh longer than
advertised everyone will say look this
is because we didn't put
india on the red list sooner uh sooner
when we should have done
and so that's why i think the average
sort of sort of the median conservative
mp thinks
actually this is going to be fine
because it would be so destructive for
the government if we did
uh move that deadline back when you
speak people in government they kind of
suck their teeth and go
well you know look we don't know for
sure that's why getting jabs in
our arms of younger people is so
important most young people of course
haven't been offered the vaccine until
relatively recently
um but yeah it the mood music is now a
lot more positive
across the whole of of of the
conservative party which means that
i think it is likely that the 21st of
june will go ahead as planned
okay just before we move on to to the
next paper i can have a comment from you
on a couple of stories related to this
one of them in fact mentioned on the
front page that
of the eye that that recommendation for
whether or not we should be vaccinating
children is
is still pending i wonder what people
are are thinking about that and of
course
today we heard again from the vaccines
minister that
compulsory vaccination for working in
the health services is being actively
considered
where do you think when both of those we
might be seeing the government head
i think they'll be taking a very
cautious approach to both because here
in the uk
uh we have residents that are more keen
to take up the vaccine than anywhere
else
in the world we should be expecting by
the end of this over 90
of uk residents to take up the vaccine
that's something to be very
very proud of but i think when you start
pushing that children might get the
vaccine especially very young children
not necessarily
older teenagers or that you could have a
compulsory element
that's where people who are completely
on board with getting their jabs might
start to feel
slightly more nervous so you have to
have a very delicate balancing act here
and i personally especially on that
second story just cannot imagine a
scenario
where you're forcing jabs into arms so
when we talk about compulsory
vaccination what we're really saying
isn't that
you know you would be actually forced to
take the vaccine we're threatening
people's jobs and the government will
have to think very carefully
about which groups aren't taking up the
vaccine and what that means practically
speaking
which members of society and groups or
society are you going to be excluding
or putting out of a job because they
didn't get their vaccine
so um you know that's very politically
difficult i think it's ethically and
morally very difficult
and i think they're going to take a very
cautious approach
and the last thing i would say about the
21st of june is i just think we have to
remember that there are different
kinds of reopening that we could see in
theory nomad could go ahead as planned
but we still have major questions around
social distancing vaccine passports
which we're going to speak about on the
front of the telegraph now
and if you were to keep say a meter rule
plus rule in place
you can open nightclubs you know you can
open mass events but to say that people
have to stay a meter apart when they're
in them is not
real freedom i think as people
understand it so it will be interesting
to see if the government goes for this
in name only or if it actually decides
to restore all those freedoms
yeah do you stephen take us through the
detail of that that story that kate was
just talking about in the front of the
telegraph their their
their lead story given the amount of
political capital the number of times
that ministers have mentioned the phrase
vaccine passport to me over the past
six to 12 months i'm slightly staggered
by this
yeah it is pretty surprising as you say
a lot of political capital has been put
into this a lot of
uh actually quite brave because this is
hugely controversial
within the conservative party the
average person uh you ask them what they
think about vaccine possibly
that seems quite reasonable you ask the
average conservative mp what they think
of
a vaccine possible and you will get a
much more mixed answer
and so the ministers who've really
fronted this have have been willing to
take political damage to do so they've
also been willing perhaps a slightly
less of a sacrifice to
have some jollies to israel to see how
the vaccine passport scheme
works there and now it seems to be
vanishing without trace now that is in
part of course because
if you follow news in israel poster
you'll know that actually the vaccine
passports
haven't worked that well um but it is it
is quite a big deal because
usually and it's happy thing in a way
usually what tends to happen is when
governments
invest a lot of time in something they
push forward with it rather than going
actually look we tried not going to
happen kate you were nodding along an
agreement that i noticed
uh yes well i think um in the same way
that this virus originated in china
and then china locked down and so did
the world israel was
you know first out of the gate with um
really getting jabs into arms while the
uk administered the first pfizer vaccine
israel stormed ahead with its rate of
vaccination and i think many countries
including the uk have been looking
to israel to see what works and what
does it now so much of the news out of
israel
is positive but one thing we've been
learning is that their green pass system
which is essentially a vaccine passport
by a different name
um has been flailing a lot of businesses
haven't been using them they find it
doesn't work very well
in many circumstances they find that
it's unnecessary and i agree with
stephen it's actually positive to see
the government not fall for the sunk
cost fallacy
and to say well we've prepared for
something but we may well not need to
use it and in a country
like the uk as i was saying before that
has such high vaccine take up
and i think there's been a question mark
over this scheme for a long time
why is it really necessary and are you
going to put this bureaucratic burden on
businesses
to check people's health status before
they go to a mass event or even before
they go
to the pub and of course boris johnson
has been writing in decades previous
about how he's opposed to any kind of
identity card he once said he would rip
one up
if he were asked to show it um so whilst
it is somewhat surprising that
we see the story on the front page of
the telegraph it does seem to be in line
with the prime minister's instincts at
the end of the day
he really doesn't want to bring in this
kind of system um stephen
we always knew that there would be any
any number of costs to
locking down in terms of the economy in
terms of the health we are now beginning
to see
the consequences and the health the
consequences in terms of health outcomes
the front of the daily mail
two years for a hip operation there will
be thousands tens of thousands of people
in an awful lot of pain as a result of
this
yeah and this is the thing is although
of course if we hadn't locked down we
would have meant the
end of modern medicine because the nhs
would have been overwhelmed by the
coronavi
coronavirus we are now for you know for
the next decade we will be living in
the post covered decade in the united
kingdom which of course is a better
position to be in most of the world
which would still be living through
having the coronavirus but
we are going to see very sad stories
like this is a huge impact on people's
lives we'll see this
playing out in education as we begin to
see the impact of school closures
we'll begin to see this unfortunately i
expect in businesses as we come out of
lockdown and some businesses
you know will not be able to survive i
think some of the the costs they've had
to bear during lockdown so
we are kind of we're leaving the
lockdown era but we will in the united
kingdom be in the post-lockdown era
for a long time and stories like this
are the beginning of that new reality
it does feel like it guys we will pause
there just to take a very quick break
but coming off immediately after the
search goes on
for the source of covert 19 the focus
once again though
turning to a laboratory in china that's
next
welcome back to the press preview at
kate anders stephen bush still here
um and stephen and take us inside the
mail and viewers who are watching the
press preview last night
may be forgiven a certain sense of deja
vu the daily mail seems to be following
up and some journalism from
uh from the weekend mi6 are now weighing
in and
and describing the theory that covert
emerged in the lab as
as feasible at no mention of likelihood
however
yeah so this is the big question about
where this particular pandemic
uh emerged from there is a laboratory in
wuhan whose job is to investigate
coronavirus so like sars the pandemic
which
affected much of southeast asia but
fortunately we we dodged that particular
bullet in the naughties sars kind of
petered out for reasons than
scientists still don't really understand
and one theory has been well
did is was this about insecure lab
practices
letting a virus out a virus mutating and
then spreading across the world
a known uh risk in society and
in a globalized economy but one which
would of course uh
have diplomatic implications because
there's already underlying issues then
many states feel that china was not
clear about how transmissible this virus
was
and then that's one reason why ourselves
as others were slightly blindsided by
how quickly
the coronavirus spread from person to
person
so it's it's it is more pressure in
journalism
on the chinese state better that these
theories uh
aren't going away and are as mi6 says
feasible i mean
it is quite something to even consider
the possibility that this could have
been the reason why the world has been
in the state it has been for the past
14 15 months but do do we think that we
are
well when you've got the americans
american security agencies looking into
this
when you've got the world health
organization looking into this the
british secret service describing it as
as feasible it's it's starting to look
like a worrying worrying possibility
certainly i think over the past 10 days
you've seen a real
change in perception on this you now
have some big international players
including president
joe biden um encouraging the the u.s
intelligence services to look into this
dr fauci
the chief medical advisor in the united
states saying that this was a
possibility you now have
mi6 a theory that was once scoffed at i
think mostly because president trump was
pushing it at the time
is now being considered as a real
possibility and i think the
the leader on the ft highlights the
importance of keeping and keeping an
open mind on this
we need to treat it like a scientific
hypothesis and we can't rule anything
out as you wouldn't do
in the scientific world and the evidence
seems to be mounting that direction now
again we're not talking about likelihood
that is for people far above our pay
grades
to actually decide um but i think the ft
is right to say that we really need to
think about this because there are
lessons to be learned 3.5 million people
have now died from this virus
and if it did escape from a lab
accidentally for whatever reason
and that's something that we need to
take real precautions about
in the future i suppose the only area
with the ft that i might slightly
disagree is they say the world health
organization
is in the best place to handle this of
course they've already published a
report where they
suggested that this was very unlikely to
be the case the evidence is now mounting
in the other direction
and i think they've had a terrible time
during the coronavirus
um suggesting that it wasn't airborne
for a very long time cutting taiwan out
of the conversations
i'm not convinced they are the most
trusted organization to handle this but
it's certainly right
that the world continues to investigate
this uh with a very high level of
scientific scrutiny
uh well guys let's let's spend the
remainder of our time together
discussing the wedding of the week
mr and mrs johnson i mean stephen on the
front of the daily telegraph we discover
the poor couple aren't even going to get
a honeymoon out of this well at least
not yet
at least not yet no they're waiting till
next year presumably because they'll be
hoping to go
abroad i mean yeah this time of year
yeah i think yeah many couples do often
sort of space out or they have a
so-called mini moon where they go to
somewhere
nearer to home and then when they've
saved a bit for the cost of them out i
guess
seeing as this was a paired down
marriage with a small reception in
downing street they
possibly aren't quite in that bracket
but in some ways this is quite a normal
uh a normal experience for people to
have obviously
for slightly abnormal reasons which is
there's a global pandemic
but there's a sort of serious economic
point here which is
the big hit than our tourist
destinations are going to face because
other people around the world will have
to make this decision and the big hit
than the global economy will face
because other people are going to have
to make this
very reasonable very responsible
decision and in terms of those
post-covered impacts
that people will not be able to return
to doing normal things like their
honeymoons if their honeymoons are being
held abroad
um is going to have big economic
consequences so this actually is quite
it's a nice story because it's happy to
see people being married but it's also
an important story because it
is part of a bigger global story a
slightly
break break from the norm kate in in
terms of the fact that boris johnson
doesn't generally like
to talk about his private life he
doesn't like to talk about his children
but today i i can tell you exactly how
much that dress cost and where it came
from
well indeed and it's a story that's
trickled because we found out yesterday
the photos were published today
obviously it's carrying in
to this week now there were some claims
made about the prime minister last week
that weren't so generous so i suspect
that they like
uh the way that they're being written up
in the papers uh this weekend and
and into the week as far as the
honeymoon goes look everybody's had to
put their life plans on hold so you
wouldn't expect the prime minister and
his
uh wife to be any exception to that and
and you know wishing the couple um all
all the best of luck but you know
hopefully
the fact that they did have this wedding
this weekend and the prime minister was
focused on that is good news for the
21st of june you would think if there
were exponential
the indian variant or if the data wasn't
looking good it's probably how they
wouldn't have spent their weekend so i'm
actually much more
hopeful and optimistic now that we're
all getting our freedoms back quite soon